The New Year. Yeah, the crunchy
meat [inaudible] I don't know that.
Hey [inaudible] come on.
[inaudible] I don't know why she just
got [inaudible] 2014 was the year of
getting to know these guys. Had you
guys a bit better. I'm not shy about it.
You really are the best
bits of this channel.
It was a year for experiments we've
dropped on linguistic teaks of travel
destinations. We pondered
whimsical questions.
Now that's not pondering Mr. Raff
give us a good pondering. There it is.
We even wandered off into an
invalid creativeness. Okay,
I retract we from that
last one. I dragged you.
Some of you may be against your will.
We skipped from idea to idea with
little care for what the Internet's was
yearning to learn about language.
Many questions when an answered
many fears surfaced because, oh,
what happened to the lessons
and how we ended up poetically,
right back where we started pondering
language. That's a good pondering.
December cleared up my backlog and ended
us in a den of animal communication and
now as promised, I'm face
to face with decipherment.
I'm even taking a step back to think
about writing systems in general.
So alongside and unwieldily
awesomely growing list of languages,
suggestions from you since the grapher
illogical threat and reveling throughout
2015 so keep on keeping me in
check after all. We will senior,
super good at that.
Subscribe for Happy New
Year and happy language.